with Star Wars Episode nine the rise of
Skywalker the Skywalker saga has finally
come to an end
but how does it stack up to the other
entries in the series let's rank every
Star Wars film from worse the best
according to the scores from critics on
Rotten Tomatoes fans were absolutely
thrilled in 1999 when Star Wars creator
George Lucas returned after a 17-year
absence and gave us the Phantom Menace
at least they were thrilled until they
actually watched the thing there were so
many problems with this one Galatia
pacing clunky dialogue and probably the
silliest most distracting character in
the entire Star Wars mythos we're
speaking of course of a certain charge
our Binks many reviewers felt the
Phantom Menace committed a cardinal sin
namely it was deathly boring in his
lacerating review The Wall Street
Journal's Joe Morgenstern took the film
to task for getting bogged down in
politics writing what I can't comprehend
is why the political details had to be
so tedious and abstract well the kids of
our nation in the world truly be
titillated by the trade wars and the
spectacle of a do-nothing Senate
despite the inclusion of a thrilling
podrace and an epic three-way lightsaber
fight the Phantom Menace was a
disappointment that many fans could have
done without the film ultimately scored
a dismal 53 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
what's worse than an unsatisfying
beginning how about a sloppy ending
unfortunately many critics felt the rise
of Skywalker was ultimately something of
a slog reviewers generally felt that the
film failed to take any of the chances
that defined its predecessor 2017 s the
last Jedi but that wasn't the only
grievance by a long shot
and her decidedly negative review
Chicago Tribune's Katie Walsh wrote
director JJ Abrams hits the gas on the
space race right away and never pauses
to let a single emotion land because the
characters are too busy scrambling
around the galaxy looking for
thingamajigs and each other the pace and
volume of plot is punishing and NUMMI
the fact that the film shamelessly undid
several plot points from the last Jedi
was seen as another major flaw as a a
doubt wrote in his AV Club review Abrams
has made what feels sometimes like a
glorified apology for successors choices
as of the making of this video the hotly
anticipated rise of Skywalker has
scored around a 58% to Rotten Tomatoes
it's hard to believe but here we are
Star Wars Episode two Attack of the
Clones focused on the theoretically epic
love story between Anakin Skywalker
played by Hayden Christensen and Padme
Amidala played by Natalie Portman
unfortunately their romance brought the
movie to a screeching halt whenever they
had a scene together the lack of
chemistry was only part of the problem
George Lucas's dialogue has never been
this jarring ly bad on the upside many
reviewers felt the film was somewhat
redeemed by the crackerjack action
sequences AV Club Scott Tobias wrote
that save for a crowd-pleasing moment
with Yoda the movie remains pretty and
inert with no authentic emotion no
cumulative power meanwhile The Wall
Street Journal's Joe Morgenstern
specifically called out George Lucas's
wouldn't dialogue writing
you can't blame actors particularly
young ones when the words put in their
mouths are almost unspeakable and the
direction seems to suck them dry of
energy or spontaneity after suffering
this attack of the critics Attack of the
Clones wound up with a disappointing 65
percent rating on Rotten Tomatoes Solo
was famously rescued by director Ron
Howard after original filmmakers Phil
Lord and Chris Miller departed and the
fact that the film needed rescuing
definitely shows in the final product
come on chewy a little bit of that
wookie oomph in his review for the beats
Kyle pinion noted the filmmakers are
working overtime to recreate the hon you
know and love from the original trilogy
rather than crafting a younger more
formative version from which he can
evolve in shorts it's clearly a movie
made by committee with many hands on
deck looking past the film's troubled
production history most reviewers
thought solo was a solid if not
altogether spectacular installment
critics generally felt its biggest flaw
was failing to stand out Alison Rose a
flick direct wrote as a standalone film
solo a Star Wars story has a good plot
interesting characters and well done
action scenes as part of the classic
franchise it comes across a little
disjointed and disconnected solo a Star
Wars story holds a decidedly so so 70%
rating on Rotten Tomatoes widely
considered the best entry of the prequel
trilogy Revenge of the Sith benefited
from an emphasis on action and on Anakin
Skywalker's turned to the dark side it's
a character development that Hayden
Christensen pulls off with a plum and
most critics were quick to
the film in his glowing review Toledo
blades Christopher Farrelly wrote
Revenge of the Sith is a terrific
riveting surprisingly effecting finale
to a series that has impacted every last
inch of our culture but not every critic
was thrilled by Revenge of the Sith
Christopher Toki of the Daily Mail wrote
episode three has the same faults as
Episode one and two
terrible dialogue and worse acting plus
two brand-new ones a confusing lack of
geographical sense and a tendency to
leave gaping plot holes I found the
whole thing a colossal disappointment
but at the end of the day most critics
were fond of the film John P McCarthy of
Real Talk reviews wrote the saga comes
full circle as both the Empire and the
seeds of the rebellion are born and the
original magic of 1977 is rediscovered
George Lucas taps into the old-fashioned
Saturday matinee quality he brought to
the first star wars along with
revolutionary craftsmanship after all
was said and done Revenge of the Sith
wound up with an 80% rating on Rotten
Tomatoes at the time of its release
Return of the Jedi was the most highly
anticipated movie of all time
as such it couldn't help but let a few
fans down although generally speaking it
was considered a satisfying if imperfect
ending to the original trilogy and a
highly positive review celia benson of
the Los Angeles Times wrote with this
last of the central Star Wars cycle
there is the sense of the closing of a
circle of leaving behind real friends it
is accomplished with the weights and a
new maturity that seemed entirely
fitting yet the movie has lost none of
its sense of fun it bursts with new
inventiveness with Jedi George Lucas may
have pulled off the first Triple Crown
of motion pictures but not every critic
was convinced Arthur Knight of The
Hollywood Reporter acknowledged the
impressive visuals but he straight-up
panned the film writing that he conveys
the sense that the machinery has already
started to wear down and the
inventiveness to wear thin to be sure
the film of balance in action but
despite its huge cast of new
intergalactic grotesques Jedi seems
woefully familiar but most critics
thought Return of the Jedi was a solid
entry perhaps not as good as people had
hoped for but none too terrible either
in his review for the San Francisco
Chronicle Peter stack wrote though it
looks almost too polished a handful of
eye smacking action scenes were
breakthroughs in pre-computer cinematic
graphics and when the film moves it does
so with blazing energy and awesome noise
the very end of an endlessly hyped
trilogy somehow puts a lump in the
throat Return of the Jedi currently
holds a respectable 82 percent rating on
Rotten Tomatoes rogue one a Star Wars
story follows the plucky band of rebels
who died getting the plans for the
Empire's infamous Space Station the
Death Star into the hands of the
rebellion the film popped in all the
right places was bolstered by terrific
acting and production design and
featured a truly jaw-dropping finale
many critics felt rogue 1 was the first
entry in the franchise that actually
felt like a war movie while others
bemoan the myriad acts of band service
and the occasionally sluggish pacing
nonetheless critics were generally way
into this movie in her glowing review
news hubs Kate Roger wrote rogue one is
dark gritty dirty brave and a Star Wars
story worth telling no it's not perfect
but it delivers us so deliciously to the
door of a new hope and it's jam-packed
with everything I need for a thrilling
few hours in that galaxy far far away
and final tally rogue 1 a Star Wars
story earned an 83% rating on Rotten
Tomatoes that's none too shabby
it certainly divided fans but most
critics really loved the last Jedi the
middle chapter of the sequel trilogy and
the only one to be directed by Rian
Johnson rather than JJ Abrams definitely
made some controversial choices with the
narrative but refreshingly the film
didn't play it safe and critics really
appreciated that
in his review for comic book movie calm
Josh Wilding wrote a superb addition to
the Skywalker saga which is sure to
leave fans with plenty to talk and argue
about star wars the last Jedi now stands
proudly alongside the Empire Strikes
Back is one of the greatest sci-fi
movies of all time sure the last Jedi
got a share of negative feedback too
although the majority of reviewers
praised the film in his review for
parade Samuel Armour Ian wrote let's not
mince words this will be remembered as
one of the best science fiction fantasy
movies of all time and this backlash
simply must stop because that's no way
to treat a near masterpiece at the end
of the day the last Jedi racked up an
enviable 91% Radia no Rotten Tomatoes
that's impossible did they've done it
coming a full decade after the
conclusion of the prequel trilogy the
force awakens was greeted warmly by
critics and fans alike its new
characters were found to be compelling
and relatable its villain was
surprisingly complex and it featured the
return of the beloved principles from
the original trilogy most of them in
major roles sure the plot beats might
have been a touch familiar but that's
easy to forget when a movie is this well
crafted critics certainly thought the
film was a major improvement on the
prequel trilogy good job kid thanks
welcome in his review for the Atlantic
Christopher or wrote with the force
awakens JJ Abrams has begun one of the
most important reclamation projects of
our time the complete eraser from
cultural memory of the Phantom Menace
and its sequels
generally speaking critics thought the
force awakens was a thrilling return to
form and an excellent Star Wars film in
its own right ultimately the film scored
an impressive 93% on Rotten Tomatoes
what can be said about a new hope that
hasn't been set already
it's a movie that won over an entire
generation one thing worth noting the
Syfy opus wasn't unanimously praised
upon its release enter 1977 review
published in the Sydney Morning Herald
Helen Cruz L even body shames r2d2
writing oh the astronomical audiences oh
the mundane story
oh the over cute little robots one fats
one thin oh the Babbitt actors the
Galactic shootout so the brilliant
technology and oh the boredom of it all
I felt a great disturbance in the force
still most reviews were extremely
positive with Dale Pollock writing in
the Santa Cruz Sentinel this is one film
that exceeds its tremendous pre-release
ballyhoo few films have ever been this
much fun to watch it conquers our dreams
lights up our hopes and leads us down
the path to the future not surprisingly
a new hope scored an impressive 93
percent rating on Rotten Tomatoes The
Empire Strikes Back dramatically raised
the stakes for our heroes and ended with
their crushing defeat a bold and unusual
move for a sequel critics were impressed
with the film to say the least
Charles Champlin of the Los Angeles
Times wrote the Empire Strikes Back
suggests strongly that the Lucas
imagination has hardly begun to be
tested it is expansive but more tightly
time framed in terms of plot I wish it
were a handful of minutes shorter but
this is my single caveat about another
richly imaginative engrossing and
spectacular motion picture in a more
recent review Jeffrey Lyles of Lyles
movie files succinctly wrote see attend
prepare to be captivated by the most
spellbinding sci-fi film of them all no
wonder the Empire Strikes Back currently
holds a 94% rating on Rotten Tomatoes
can you believe it check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about star wars are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]